>> THANK YOU, TREY.
TREY: BEFORE WE SAY GOOD
NIGHT.
THERE IS A DASH OF HOPE.
NOT MANUFACTURED OR
CONTRIVED BUT HOPE GROUNDED
IN REASON.
HOPE IS NOT JUST A FEELING
IT SAY COMMITMENT.
INTENTIONAL, EXPRESSION OF
OUR WILL.
SOMETIMES WE HAVE TO DO
THINGS EVEN WHEN THEY ARE
UNPLEASANT AND HARD, VETERAN
A DAY IS PERFECT TIME TO BE
REMINDED THAT GENERATIONS OF
AMERICANS HAVE DONE WHAT
THEY MUST, RATHER THAN WHAT
THEY WANTED.
IT IS WHY WE CELEBRATE
DEDICATED SERVICE AND NOT
DEDICATED FEELINGS,
AOCCASIONALY WE HAVE TO WILL
OURSELVES TO LOOK ON THE
BRIGHT SIDE NO MATTER HOW
DARK IT SEEMS IN THIS CASE,
IF LUKE HARD ENOUGH, YOU --
LOOK HARD OF IF YOU YOU CAN
SEE THE LIGHT ON THE
HORIZON.
ONLY ONE PRESIDENT IN MY
LIFETIME WON A REAL MANDATE.
THAT WAS RONALD REAGAN.
THAT FORMER GOVERNOR
CALIFORNIA HAD A MANDATE SO
COMPELLING HIS CRITICS WERE
FORCED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
ENORMITY OF HIS VICTORY.
THERE ARE REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS WHO WANT TO
MANDATE TUESDAY NIGHT FOR
THEIR POLICIES AND THE
MANNER IN WHICH THEY GOVERN,
RON DESANTIS AND BRIAN KEMP
WANT MANDATES.
AND CHRIS TSUNAMI, GREG
ABBOTT, HENNE McCASTER,
CHRISTIE GNOME, AND AND
OTHERS HAVE VERY GOOD
NIGHTS, WHY?
WHY DO KNOWS LEADER AT THE
STATE LEVEL DO WELL EVEN AND
FEDERAL OFFICE SEEKERS DO
NOT?
IF YOU ARE A REPUBLICAN A
CONSERVATIVE, YOU SHOULD
CELEBRATE.
THIS SHOULD GIVE
HOPE, CONSERVATISM MEANT A
LIMITED ROYAL FOR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, IF FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS A LIMITED
ROLE THAT LEAVES MORE FOR
THE STATES THAT USED TO BE
WHAT REPUBLICANS BELIEVED.
50 LABORATORIES, FOR
DEMOCRACY.
IF YOU STILL BELIEVE THAT.
YOU SHOULD BE EMBOLDENED BY
THE RESULTS OF TUESDAY NIGHT
AND ARGUING FOR MATTERS TO
BE RETURNED TO THE STATE
WHERE OUR ELECTED OFFICIALS
ENJOY OVERWHELMING
POPULARITY.
>> ON THE HOUSE SIDE THE BIG
WAVE DID NOT COME, IN IT
DOES CHANGE HANDS A 26 EL
TRICKLE OF
218 WILL STOP THE BIDEN
AGENDA, IF THEY UNIFY.
WILL THEY UNIFY OR
CANNIBALIZE ITSELF?
FAME IS NOT A VIRTUE.
OR A STRATEGY TO GOVERN.
ON THE SENATE SIDE THERE
WERE BRIGHT SPOTS MARCO
RUBIO AND TIM SCOTT SURFACED
EVEN LOFTY EXPECTATIONS,
THEY PROVED ABLE TO REACH
VOTE ARE GROUPS THAT
REPUBLICANS WILL WANT AND
NEED IN THE ELECTIONS TO
COME.
ACCORDING TO EXIT POLLS SOME
REPUBLICANS DID BETTER WITH
SUBURBAN WOMEN AND HISPANIC
VOTERS AND AFRICAN-AMERICAN
MEN, DID NOT TRANSLATE INTO
ELECTORAL SUCCESS, NOT THIS
TIME.
BUT IT IS WORTH NOTING.
THE GREAT THING ABOUT LIVING
IN A DEMOCRACY IS THERE IS
ALWAYS ANOTHER ELECTION.
A CHANCE TO LEARN AND
CORRECT AND GROW AND REFINE.
BASED ON VICTORY SPEECHES
FROM GOVERNOR DESANTIS AND
SENATOR TIM SCOTT, PERHAPS,
THE NEXT ELECTION CYCLE HAS
ALREADY BEGUN.
ON THE EDGE OF EVEN THIS
DARK NIGHT, THERE IS LIGHT.
I THINK IT IS COMING.
YOU MAY EVEN WANT